Now that we understand the components of RPC
latency, let's understand the sources of overhead that creeps
in in carrying out all the different functions, going
from the client to the server and back to
the client. So far as the client is
concerned, this looks like an innocuous procedure call, right?
So it just says, I want to call a
procedure S.foo, and here are the arguments. Well unfortunately,
this call is not a simple procedure call but
it is a remote procedure call. And the sources
of overhead that creeps in, in a remote procedure
call, are marshaling, data copying, control transfer and protocol
processing. So we'll look at each one of these
things in more detail. Now how can we reduce
the overhead in the kernel? What we want to
do is, think what the hardware gives you in order
to reduce the latency incurred for each of these components of the RPC latency.